[Music]
it's pretty fitting that this episode of
new releases drops during star wars
celebration because there's a ton of
disney games coming this week i don't
want to go all Charlie Kelly on you guys
but I think this conspiracy could go all
the way to the top don't forget to Like
and subscribe to keep up with all the
latest theories now let's see what's
launching this week telltale is
literally launching into space with
guardians of the galaxy episode 1 titled
tangled up in blue actually I wouldn't
be surprised if all the episodes ended
up being named after Bob Dylan songs in
any case you can expect the usual twists
and turns as you make dialogue choices
and universe altering decisions for
everyone's favorite space rebels
star-lord Gamora Drax Groot and Rocket
are all here for an original adventure
that won't spoil any of the upcoming
movie but of course you can always visit
our gamespot universe channel for plenty
of discussion on that tell tales
guardians of the galaxy comes to ps4
xbox one pc ios and android on tuesday
april eighteenth let's move from rocket
ships to rad motorbikes full throttle
remastered gives the 1995 classic some
shiny new graphics better sound better
controls and developer commentary for
you purists out there all the original
voice work is intact and you can swap
between the new look and the retro
graphics at any time if you missed the
ride the first time around here's the
gist it's a point-and-click adventure
from Double Fine the same team that
brought you modern adventures like
broken age and head Lander full throttle
remastered revs on to ps4 Vita and PC on
April eighteenth
speaking of 90s adventure games getting
remastered let's talk about the silver
case you probably know suda51 from games
like no more heroes and killer 7 but he
also directed the silver case in 1999
it's the story of a bunch of crazy
murders in a city called 24 wards and
you take control of a detective and a
journalist trying to piece it all
together the remake brings the case up
to a shiny or 1080p resolution redesigns
the UI and includes new music and
scenarios you can start solving the
mystery on ps4 on the 18th apparently
April is just the month to bring back
old games because the Disney afternoon
collection packages together six
nostalgia filled 8-bit games ducktales
one and two chip and dale rescue rangers
one and two darkwing duck and tailspin
these aren't remakes either the games
look and play exactly how you remember
them all though because they aren't the
easiest platformers out there the
collection does add a rewind feature to
let you undo any of those bad jumps you
can also jump into time attack and boss
rush modes and compete in online
leaderboards for the best scores it all
starts on the 18th on ps4 xbox one and
pc sorry Nintendo switch owners but you
know what is coming to switch wonderboy
the Dragons trap which is yet another
remake of a retro platformer this one
features brand-new hand-drawn graphics
new music a new female protagonist and
more difficulty levels if you've never
played wonder boy you're in for an
adventure full of various animals with
different powers like a fire spitting
lizard and a flying hawk and yes you can
switch back to the original look if you
want to you can do all that fun stuff on
ps4 xbox one pc and nintendo switch on
the 18th okay let's review disney owns
marvel so guardians of the galaxy
already belongs to them full throttle
was originally developed by lucasarts
and disney bought them in 2012 and
that's a point-and-click adventure game
just like the silver case disney
afternoon collection is self-explanatory
and ducktales released in 1989
the same year as the original wonderboy
3 just as I suspected well anyway those
are the big games will be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with a
jumbo-sized episode of new releases next
week